vendredi matin premiers flocons de neige
dans le département et première mise en
action pour le dispositif viabilité
hivernale active depuis la mi novembre
jusqu'au 15 mars pour l'agglomération
saint-quentinoise tout se pilote depuis
cet entrepôt à tra c'est là qu'est
stocker le sel pour l'hiver 1200 tonnes
on a dix camions neufs camion donc pour
la casse qui est un camion pour la ville
de montigny-le-bretonneux à montigny le
bretonneux justement c'est patrick
râteau le responsable de la voirie qui a
l'oeil sur le planning de ces cinquante
agents mobilisables 24 heures sur 24 et
7 jours sur 7
chacun a donc une tâche bien spécifique
et un secteur à traiter dans la ville et
dans un quartier bien défini les leçons
de l'hiver 2010 avec son lot de
véhicules bloqués sur les chaussées ont
été bien tirés des bulletins alerte
météo sont édités dès que besoin et
chaque équipe dispose d'une cartographie
des zones à déneiger
on sait également équipée de nouveaux
engins comme les mises en jambes au
salage de houari qui sont qui fond en
hiver du salage et dans d'autres saisons
d'autres prestations sur la ville
l'hydro gommage traitement des graffitis
plus de véhicules et des engins plus
performants sylvain charrier et
chauffeurs ce à l'heure tout est
automatisé depuis ce petit boîtier jaune
à l'intérieur du camion vous pouvez dosé
comment le pourcentage de celles par
rapport aux nectars et vous pouvez voir
la largeur du j'ai réglé donc pas pour
la saumure un système expérimental sur
montigny le bretonneux
c'est un mélange de sel d'eau qui fait
que quand on l'est quand on le met par
terre
la nef est normalement n'a pas repassé
que la neige ne tient pas ne tint pas
porter une bouillie de sel comme
l'appellent les spécialistes 80 % de
celles solide et 20% de selles liquides
un procédé qui sera actif à partir de la
mi-décembre
pas de neige annoncées dans les
prochains jours